we both grew up very Catholic yes you're
in Boston right yeah yeah I was just in
Boston doing Castlerock are you doing
Kappa yeah that's what a great city it's
an amazing city I love it I do love that
town I grew up there I grew up Irish
Catholic in Boston which is such a
cliche yeah and everyone in my family
who had we had to participate in the
church so I was a lectern which meant I
would get up and do some readings every
now and then they would want like a
young kid to come out and read oh yeah
or something like that electron was oh
like a piece of wood it is the actual
thing you stand behind right I was that
for a while I think they had a thing
that was called there was the name that
they had yeah I think you're right where
where it's for the kid that comes out
and and and they said oh and you have a
good reading voice you can do that but
because I did that I wasn't an altar boy
and I kind of felt like a Lee altar boys
they get like a cool outfit and they're
in charges they get I mean you were an
altar boy
right I was an altar boy that was my
first theatrical experience you know
learning user and yeah learning cues
ringing the bells at the right time
bringing up the wine you know that all
that I had all all these
responsibilities and then he had the
learn lines to he had the I came in
right after the Latin though so I didn't
have to learn the Latin Rite me too it
was all the Catholic Church was Latin
and then overnight it changed to people
with guitars singing Kumbaya yeah there
you go
and just jamming Jesus's name in there
yeah weird I remember those songs yeah
we are all together remember that one no
I don't yeah my dad was actually the
leader of the choir he was a folk singer
in Greenwich Village at the time and a
Catholic so he he wound up leading the
choir with those folk masters were you a
a good kid as an altar boy or to do well
he's
you know New York you can't just say New
York if that defense worked Giuliani
would have said that a long time ago
more like Moscow so yeah I was I was a
good boy but I was always tempted you
know when we were in the you know
backstage it's called the altar anyway
so yeah there were there hosts and stuff
and communion wife yeah and you know
when the when they were unconsecrated
and they were in the you know the closet
you know and you could maybe take a
couple out mmm
yeah I took a stack back to school one
day after you ate the communion wafers
as a snack they were not a stack of them
it was pretty good yeah and then when
you're in the packet a little almond
butter on there that's pretty good for
the shock value you know hey look but
you know hey hey girls freaking out
that's all those are hosts yeah yeah not
blessed yeah haven't transmogrified
and they're low-calorie so and then the
wine of course you know which you know
there was this priest named father
Ratigan and you'd do the morning Mass
like it's 7:30 in the morning and he's
like you have to pour the wine and he's
into the chalice and he's gone you know
chugged it down poor guy yeah free wine
every day cheap wine those not very good
headaches you know yeah yeah it's one
thing I learned about Thanksgiving this
is a little tip for Thanksgiving you
know how thinks giving can you know
degra date into you know family's bad
that's a good wine just try it next time
just spend a little extra money on some
good wine instead of cheap to the cheap
wine and the beer and the football all
day just have some really good wine and
maybe a little you know and then
grandma will calm down take it real easy